[Music]
play a car con i'm feeling inspired i
feel like we need to redeem the karakan
in the eyes of the public we haven't
played the karaoke yet
on the speed run i don't know why i'm
playing it i just feel
feel inspired okay so already not a good
setup by white by the way already a
mistake now e takes d5 in itself is not
a bad move but in conjunction with
knight c3 it is i've explained that
before
at length in previous speed runs the
bottom line is that it blocks the c pawn
and that does two things it doesn't
allow white to play c3
nor does it allow y to play c4 and both
of those moves are indispensable tools
which create tension in the center now
the pawn on d4 is simply speaking a
weakness and so we develop our pieces
naturally knight c6 knight f6 doesn't
matter how we start knight c6 f6 let's
go knight f6
bishop g5 now are we worried about
bishop takes f6 well
you know what the response that is
having watched my speed and you're
almost never concerned about
a slight
uh you know visual
damage of your pawn structure especially
when it when it comes at the cost of
your opponent's development in fact we
want white to play bishop takes f6
because after we played gf
and i've explained this before those
double pawns can actually help you
create a more robust center bishop b5 is
good i think white is playing this as
best as he can play
okay now what we shouldn't do is go e6
prematurely by by going e6 we we lock
out
our own bishop since white hasn't played
this in a good way we have the luxury of
getting the bishop outside the pawn
chain let's go bishop g4 we could have
also gone bishop f5
i don't think it makes an essential
difference f3 okay well that actually is
another serious weakness
and it's a great move to provoke now i
think we'll drop back to
either f5 or even d7 now that white has
played f3
it might make sense for us to come back
to d7 um or even perhaps to see it but
let's stick with the original plan and
go bishop f5 and perhaps it will provoke
even the move g4 which is not out of the
question by the way knight e2 okay let's
continue developing with e6
knight g3 now this is not a trade that
we want this is not a
transformation of the pawn structure
that we want for obvious reasons
first of all the e-file opens and white
can give a nasty check anyone
second of all the d5 pawn loses its
support we want to preserve this pawn
chain that's important so we drop our
bishop back to g6
now other ideas in this position that
you should keep in mind
is in the karakan in general the move
queen d8 to b6
is very very often a a good move a very
annoying move for white to face
and the reason i'm singling out the car
gun is because you literally push the c
pawn on move one opening up this
possibility you should always keep that
move in mind queen b6 puts pressure on
d4 it reinforces the knight and
obviously it also stares down the b2
pawn
in general a lot of queen side moves
here rook c8 queen b6
are are are very good in a wide variety
of positions now we don't need to rush
with queen b6 and i think if we're
playing this in the spirit of the karo
khan
then we should probably focus on
completing our development first and
then we can worry about
uh moves like queen b6 so to complete
our development we need to get our dark
square bishop out
okay well where should we put it
well i like both e7 and d6 and both of
these moves have their upsides and
downsides i feel like
bishop e7 might be a little bit more
prudent given that we're going to be
castling kingside
and given that we might want to move our
queen away from d8 if we castle king's
side and then move our queen away from
deep we do need to keep in mind that
bishop takes f6 would ruin our pawn
structure this takes that headache
um off of our
you know out of our out of our uh site
so
yeah black is okay f4 is a great move i
was
waiting to see if
he would know this idea f4 is a
fantastic move actually and i think the
only way for
white to get a feasible position here
everything else in white is much worse
okay so now i think it's very important
to react accurately yeah so
the reaction to this movement white
wants to push the spawn down to f5 which
that is not terribly dangerous but it's
annoying
because after e takes f5 knight takes f5
white gets this nice knight and we
really don't want to give away our light
squared bishop if we can
avoid it because
white's got weak light squares and we
want to be able to control them so let's
start by playing h6 and seeing what our
opponent does and we'll base our next
move off of our opponent's response now
if bishop h4 will happen which i'm
expecting
there will be a lot of moving parts to
take into account so here's my logic
when there's an annoying idea and you
want to stop it
the most tempting thing to do is to make
a move like queen d7 right but that pins
the queen and that's not the only way of
stopping threats there's what i call
type 2 prophylaxis
knight h5 there's bishop takes c7 and
then knight takes h5
which is that you you you basically
allow the threat right you allow the
move to happen
but you've made a move to in order to
take the sting out of it you do
something such that the move is no
longer quite as dangerous as it would
have been otherwise
and one typical
application of that one one way that you
do that is you you make sure that the
move doesn't come with a threat you take
away
the creation of a threat which allows
you to do whatever you want to do what
so in this particular context what am i
talking about
what threat does f5 create well it
attacks the bishop what if we move the
bishop back and we could also
by the way we could also castle
and then respond to f5 with bishop h7
just kind of ignoring
okay bishop takes f6 is not good
that's really weird i mean first our
opponent
dropped the bishop back now he takes
that seems very inconsistent my guess is
he wants a knight h5 which is kind of an
ingenious idea but it's not dangerous at
all
that's good for us i mean now we have
the two bishops f5 no this is i have no
idea why you traded
and this is a classic example of
keeping the tension right in fact we
might even have better moves than
castling but
i want to play it simple we castle we're
now threatening d4
by the way the reason we couldn't play
bishop takes d4 here
hopefully you saw this is because if
queen takes d4 and the knight is pinned
okay
no automatic moves
we have to calculate the intermediate
move bishop takes d4 check now
unfortunately
i'm afraid that it doesn't quite work as
intended
does anybody see why bishop takes d4
check what's going to be the problem at
the end of the line
why can't we take on d4 and then take on
e6 what's going to be the issue so the
issue is going to be
no
well no f7 is not an issue because we
take on d4 that's a check
yeah bishop takes c6 at the end of the
line is going to be a problem because
the queen is going to be making contact
with the bishop so
we have to play f66 i'll show this on
the board after the game but i don't
want to go into those tactical
complexity there's no need for that
our position is perfectly fine as it is
now i think it's finally time we have to
speed up a little bit for
my favorite karu khan move
which is what which is the move queen b6
yeah now i think it's it's perfect time
for queen b6 it hits the bishop hits the
pawn it essentially forces another trade
and after pawn takes c6 we have the two
bishops they're both on really really
nice squares
and we're gonna have a great center so
black is much better but we've got less
than four minutes so let's speed up a
little bit bc and ideas here to keep in
mind first of all we're attacking b2
second of all we're x-raying the d4 pawn
how does that help us well it creates
ideas like e6 e5
that uh put even more pressure on the
spawn but our opponent for some reason
did not
defend the pawn now a lot of people are
afraid to capture this pawn just period
full stop
and often the worries are totally
overblown one thing i would point out is
that rook b1 isn't even possible because
there's a bishop on h7 guarding that
square and even if it was possible it
wouldn't even come close
to trapping the queen
okay but but if you're worried about
that you can make a very sort of russian
school of chess move here that
uh that gets the queen out of
danger even though it's not really in
danger to begin with what am i talking
about
we're not gonna necessarily play this
well we actually might play this move
we will play this move queen but not b6
queen b6 is a little passive
i like queen b5
this simultaneously offers a queen trade
and aims at the knight
and if the queen trade happens then the
c file opens then we can get a rook to
see it and attack this backward pawn on
c3
okay
now we need to keep making improving
moves
and there are many many possible plans
in a position like this
many many possible plans i like to move
e5 you've got the two bishops so it
makes a lot of sense to
open up the center
other ideas include playing a move like
rook f7 and doubling rooks on the f file
bishop d3 is a great move too i actually
i really like the move bishop d3 because
this gets the bishop into the game
and it creates
you know we're not going to win the
knight white's going to defend it but
that's
you know we're going to follow up on
that
no c takes b5 is not bad for the black
bombshell yes it creates another pawn
island but there's no isolated pawns so
i'm expecting rook f2 in which case we
have a really nice follow-up move you
can start thinking about what that might
be
if rook f2 okay so oh
wow that is an impressive move because
bishop takes c6 there's queen takes e6
check sorry bishop e2 there's queen e6
check and uh and queen takes e2 so let's
uh let's defend the e pawn instead yeah
rookie obviously
we also could contemplate moving the
king away just just to avoid any such
difficulties
rook e1
okay so the moment i see this move i say
wait a minute the rook has left the f
file which means we immediately need to
reinforce our control over the f file
and that means moving the bishop away
let's move it to g5 in order to also
prevent knight e2 to f4 restricting
fully this knight on e2 that would have
also been our move after rook f2
so we're we do have a threat and your
eyes should be firmly fixed on the
knight on e2 because it's being attacked
by two pieces the bishop and the queen
an idea would be to dislodge the rook
from e1
and once i say that you should
immediately see the idea of bishop d2
which
our opponent prevented
he prevented one
application of that idea but not another
one there is another
mirror application of that same exact
concept which wins material and that is
what
what am i talking about
bishop
nazi well yeah bishop c2 is great too
but i'm talking about bishop b3 chick
and bishop f2
there should be three check and bishop
after we can even pre-move bishop f2
because white has only one
legal move
and again this might come down to a bit
of a time pressure situation so i might
have to stop explaining quite as
extensively
and just focus on winning the game but
we still have a little bit of time left
yeah this might be the first free move
of the speed run
at h5 okay our opponent collapses yeah i
mean knight h5 just loses everything the
e2 knight is now hanging
what should we take first well
it doesn't matter i would even take the
knight on e2 first i think the clinical
surgical move is to take the knight on
e2 first and the reason why is that this
also hits yeah well this is exactly the
reason a move like this
could be uh annoying to face in time
pressure it threatens checkmate
um but in this case we have a move that
simply disarms any possible threats for
the rest of the game and what movement
am i talking about
yeah we just take the knight and then we
take the rook with the other bishop and
then we have a backrank mate on top of
that and that's part of the
the the advantage of
positioning the queen on b5
and for style points we could even play
queen f1 shock very nice
solid positional game
we didn't do we didn't play any any hero
ball we made simple moves and
uh and and we won a a pretty smooth game
so i'm i'm honestly surprised that our
opponent did not go for a a
serious line
against the karo khan i mean this is
usually what most beginners do
but this is you know
this is not an 1800 level
response to the karkon it's not that
white is like lost or anything white
white probably isn't even worse
but it's you know you're not contending
for anything you're giving black a very
comfortable game
so
bishop g5 knight c6 so we're developing
bishop b5
yeah bishop g4 some people hesitate to
put the bishop on before when there is
no knight on f3 i noticed that
and
you shouldn't be most cases you
shouldn't be i mean sometimes it's it's
awkward to do that in this particular
case i don't mind the fact that the
knight isn't developed yet in fact we
ended up benefiting from that because he
played f3 which i think is
probably inaccurate i think white should
have played knight g knight ge2 perhaps
yeah encouraging f3
okay so bishop f5
we're not afraid of course of anything
like g4 our bishop just comes back to g6
this is
uh pseudo pseudo activity knight tree
2v6
knight truth through bishop g6
um
and the funny thing is i was quite
impressed that our opponent was familiar
with this idea of f4 f5 i believe that
this is actually there this has a name
and it's it's called i think it's called
the botvinic idea or like some people
refer to this uh name this idea after
bob vinick
um because bob vinnick kind of pioneered
this f4 f5 idea in
structures where black has
this pawn chain f7 e6 t5
f4 f5 disrupts completely this pawn
chain if it works and i've even applied
this myself
in a
nice game that i won over over conrad
holt
grandmaster many years ago
now it's a different situation but
you'll see the similarity immediately so
this position
is on the board it's white to play
what did i do in this position
yeah f4
now f4 looks like it weakens the e4
square and opens the diagonal but in
fact it's a good move and the idea here
is a little bit different it's not to
destroy the pawn chain
the idea here is to open up the bishop
on a2
hopefully you notice that bishop and the
fact that it's
blocked by the e61 and you can push c5
whenever you want to do that and after e
takes f5 there's even cool ideas
like this obviously i wasn't going to do
that because knight g60 doesn't have to
take but after rook takes f5 this
constant idea of c5 becomes a big
problem so black
didn't respond but what ended up
happening is that now he has
a really really weak pawn on e6 and he
has a weak square on g6 and i used both
of those things uh and won the game so
okay back to
speedrun just an example of a similar
idea
here f4 is played in order to disrupt
and destroy the pawn chain but we go h6
and then we go bishop h7
and bishop takes f6 is the beginning of
the end but how do i play f5 we would
have just castled
and the funny thing is f takes e6 we
don't even have to recapture we have
what move
that
i think it works i i think it white
doesn't have anything against it
but at least it should be considered
g5 yeah g5 trapping the bishop
anytime you have a knight like this on
g3
you should remember that uh g7 g5 or g2
g4 become serious ideas the bishop is
trapped and i don't think white has any
way to
exploit the weakness of black's king
here
i don't see anything off the top of my
head
but we could also play f6 and we're
totally fine here the f file is open
white's king is flimsy
our pieces are better placed the g5 is
now still a threat
so
type 2 prophylaxis right you don't
physically prevent f5 but you take the
sting out of it by getting the bishop
off of g6
yeah e6 is weak but you know just
because you have one little problem
or structural defect doesn't mean your
position is bad right
e6 is weak but it's easy to protect
you can always bring your queen up to d7
you know in certain cases you can bring
your bishop back to f5 so and it's not
that easy to attack that pawn
because if white goes rook f1 then white
opens the f file
white moves the queen the d4 pawn is
weak so white has a lot more weaknesses
than black
but yeah after he took the bishop
and and gave us the two bishops um this
this got really really nasty
just to show really quickly bishop takes
d4 check king h1 fv6 it might end up
working there was a long line here i
couldn't really calculate it so let's
say white takes on f8 and then takes on
c6
now this doesn't quite win a piece
because black has the desperado bishop
takes knight
but now white has his own desperado
which takes b7
and you have a hilarious line where both
players are doing
desperados but in this position
white has a very strong response both
rooks are hanging
so the temptation is to play bishop
takes rook but you have a much more
quiet move just rook b1
and now the bishop is attacked and as is
the rook and if you go to rook b8 you
capture the bishop and simultaneously
defend the other bishop maybe black has
some
tactical idea here but why go for this
right this was totally unnecessary and
it probably also loses so for that
reason we took back
yeah and here we go queen b6
this is already a really really bad
position white probably should have
defended this pawn
but then we would have gone e5 and now
the c pawn has been so you can't even go
c3 this is garbage
total total garbage and once we take b2
the rest is
the rest is history the only other thing
i wanted to point out is that after
queen b5
uh some of you are concerned that the
pawn structure
is ruined here or or is damaged not
really i mean yeah you get another pawn
island i think pawn islands are
overrated i almost never think about end
games in terms of the number of pawn
islands
um because it's more
like how easy are those pawns to defend
well very easy right a6 can defend b5
these islands are totally
self-sufficient the e6 pawn also easy to
defend
and the benefit is that the c file is
open so as i pointed out we can go rook
c8 we can also go b4 in certain cases
and undermine the c3 pawn so there could
even be a benefit from the c6 pawn
becoming
a b5 pawn
yeah and and nobody trades in these
situations right bishop d3 and
we would have gone bishop g5 here as
well to go to e3
and it's over rook a8 is one more
vigilant move not taking the knight
and sorry and after bishop g5
spotting bishop e3 bishop f2 is also
important and now white's position falls
apart okay
um and that that's that
so a simple game
shows us that the karaoke lives on
and uh important moments were how to
meet f4
not panicking because there's a there's
a threat
and
actually allowing it to happen
but taking the sting out of it
um
what else did we do that's that's nice
queen b6 yeah so the queen b6 idea in
the karaoke even if there's no bishop on
b5 can be very very powerful the queen
on b6 is
super safe and it's sort of lording over
the entire queen side
and then
um yeah not
like automatically going for inter
mezzos just because they look cool oh we
can grab this pawn to check first
noticing the consequences of that before
you you go for it
and uh finally
yeah using the queen trade weaponizing
the queen trade not being afraid to grab
b2 and then
uh
seeing this idea of dislodging a piece
from its protection of another piece
right bishop e3 bishop f2
or bishop d2 a very powerful method for
winning material
and with that i'm going to hit the sack
hope you guys enjoyed the games have a
good one thanks for hanging out see you
guys
[Music]